bonjour si le baril bonjour mouïsse viol
dont vous êtes à du cercle démocratique
de la martinique et vous êtes surtout en
lice dans le sud pour les prochaines
législatives du mois de jeûne avant-hier
steve du mari avant-hier nous recevions
philippe petit le président de l'udps et
y candidat dans le sud lui aussi et nous
disait dans son caddie que sa forme à
suite est en contact avec le cercle en
revue de ces législatives qu'en est il
alors d'abord je dis bonjour aux
auditeurs de martinique première puisque
c'est une première pour moi
et dans cette première je vais annoncer
aussi par rapport à ce qu'a déclaré
monsieur philippe petit je suis le
candidat des petits et aussi des gonds
oui mais l'appareil de tractations entre
le départ alors je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
reçu personnellement des tractations
je verrai avec mon président il n'évite
pas mais pas même une seconde je vais
avec mon président personnellement je ne
suis pas pour du tout pas même une
seconde
oui et pourquoi n'en parle alors je ne
sais pas je n'ai aucune gêne ni aucune
idée mais je suis totalement contre
personnellement le cercle démocratique
de lamartine et qui propose juin gaudou
dans le centre atlantique
d'autres candidatures annoncées dans les
prochaines semaines concernant ici aussi
la notion certainement accès le cow boys
in dans le nom pourquoi y aller vous
c'est ivry mari pourquoi êtes vous
candidat dans le sud dans cette
législative ben tout d'abord parce que
je tiens à souligner néanmoins à
préciser
l'absence regrettable de notre député du
sud notre ainsi un début du sud monsieur
jean philippe belloc y étaient présents
que cette semaine sur 49 semaines
assemblée nationale et ça je trouve ça
inadmissible sanctionnable et c'est pour
cette raison que je me présente aux
élections législatives et pas
suffisamment présents sur les bancs de
la samba suffisamment tel parc de
travail casas en commission pas
suffisamment donné sur les douze
derniers mois quelques questions parce
que les élections arrivent mais il n'est
pas suffisamment présents c'est pas
comme ça qu'on fait avancer les choses
en politique il n'est pas ça et je les
vois il n'est pas sa place
il n'est surtout pas un plat
je viens point de sa place et ce sera
suffisant pour convaincre les électeurs
ça ce ne sera pas seulement suffisant
mais ce sera déjà un premier pas je
préfère aller pas à pas dans un escalier
plutôt que d'aller trop vite dans un
ascenseur c'est votre première
participation à une élection
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à y aller
aujourd'hui vous êtes arrivé comme ce
matin pour vous dire je vais vous
répondre
tout d'abord je suis totalement contre
le pantouflage le poteau flash le
cartonnage le cas les sondages c'est un
mot qui a été inventé par moi même et il
faut savoir que j'observe la vie
politique depuis un certain nombre
d'années et je vois que les caleçons se
passe vous avez dû voir ce qu'on a fait
naître ou adidas et c'est très important
que vous expliquiez le pantouflage et
lequel se nage alors vous à commencer
par lequel son agent se passait quel ado
qui a passé lequel sera le théâtre de
monsieur léautaud n'allez pas trop vite
c'est moi qui je continue donc je
poursuis local zonage c'est quand une
personne en politique on va diriger en
transmet au petit poucet son caleçon
deux géants de sorte qu'ils puissent
marcher j'ai pas terminée de sorte
qu'ils puissent marcher sur les même pas
de ce gir donc pas il ya fred barry
chagny déjà fini leur entre autres mais
y'a aussi monsieur c est monsieur le
team i entre être bon alors lequel se
nage concept que vous avez inventé vous
êtes contre alors totalement contre
et pourtant le plagiat sabri le peu
qu'elles lâchent la dernière élection
lors des dernières élections
légistatives le peuple a dit ok pour ce
qu'elle sonnait grave passage de
qu'elles sont mais vous imaginez le
caleçon de mu marianne c'est tout à fait
normal c'est tout à fait normal
en martinique il nous faut arrêter ça je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que ça tue
la politique martiniquaise je les vois
le député je les vois quand il pose une
question il ne travaille pas pour la
martinique
ils essaient de gagner des points je me
souviens quand monsieur letchimy s'est
élevée pour une certaine question
monsieur ni là où j'ai pu le soutenir
mais quand il n'est pas du même bord
politique
eloi fusent et ça c'est inadmissible
sanctionnant avait expliqué le
camionnage
le pantouflage alors appât to fail c'est
totalement différent puisqu'il s'agit
d'une personne publique qui met ses
pantoufles doubiens sont privés donc ça
n'a rien à voir mais j'insiste pour cac
et le cartonnage sur la plante ouvrage
lettres ou isation je suis contre ces
deux systèmes c'est tout simplement sur
les margelles besoin d'un tunisien on a
toujours besoin d'un par air n'a
toujours besoin d'être introduit quelque
part ainsi le peuple rien d'autre et
c'est ça que les martiniquais n'ont pas
où aller
comment vous allez obtenir le parrainage
du peuple on sent bien que vous avez le
verbe haut que vous avez des idées très
arrêtées sur la chose maintenant le plus
difficile consiste maintenant à séduire
l'électorat et salons dénonçant le
pantouflage locascio nages ce sera alors
sur verdon sachez que je ne suis pas là
pour séduire l'électorat
je viens avec mon programme qu'ils
soient contents qu'ils soient pas
contents c'est mon programme
s'ils ont envie d'accéder à mon
programme ils voteront
s'ils n'ont pas envie peu importe je
vais avec mon programme et de retrouver
mes gars croient par exemple ben
entrecôte en matière de santé une
accessibilité plus en plus intéressantes
par exemple les personnes malades au
logement aux assurances tout simplement
je veux aller plus loin dans la lutte
contre le cancer le cancer du côlon jeu
des préférences qui passa trois à cinq
ans quand vous dites que vous voulez
aller plus loin qu'en matière de santé
au niveau agit certes vous pouvez
établir des textes de loi qui
permettrait que la prise en charge soit
plus efficace plus bien sûr bien sûr
entre autres bien sûr il nous faut aller
plus loin il nous faut aller plus loin
changer nos méthodes politiques oui
parce que lorsqu'on parle de pantouflage
et de kelso nage je penserai que vous
pourriez mettre en avant par exemple la
question du cumul des mandats ou bien le
nombre de mandats que pourrais je n'ose
même pas encore en parler mais si osé
non j'avoue être alesi allez-y c'est
inadmissible quand je vois notre député
monsieur ni l'or aux gens fiq j'appelle
jeune fille je le connais très bien
alias jj va nous dire que c'est un
copain aussi bien sûr d'accord c'est un
ami quand je vois le bord du chemin
mais bien sûr aux percussions je vous
dit quelque chose
le fait de dire à un candidat qu'il
n'est pas le bon candidat
n'empêche pas de le connaître et de le
remercier pour ce qu'il a fait beau la
matinée mais sans cette route si vous
étiez un ami ceci est vrai vous ait pu
lui dire bien longtemps à l'avant ce que
ce qu'il fait en 2000 sur le long de la
crise en 2009 lors de la crise en
martinique
j'étais au goûter de ces gens là j'étais
jeunes gens là j'ai pas fini
j'étais jeune et j'avais l'impression
qu'on aurait entendu j'avais
l'impression que si je la traduisent
exactement ma pensée ces gens là vous
dites tous ces gens là c'est qui le
miment exactement le mime danseur
nationalités au dessus du mime
extrêmement en plus nos pilotes
je suis très déçu du mil on nous a parlé
des prix bas toute la population se
reconnaît
on doit ce v6 tellement bas aujourd'hui
dans les magasins et la plupart du temps
et des passagers n'est pas terminée
c'est la faute aux mines ça entre autres
on perd notre temps à gagner des points
pour la cité m alors que le boulot de
député c'est maintenant c'est pas demain
malheureusement je ne sais pas si vous
vous rendez compte 47 47 59 semaines il
a été brisé cette fois set cette semaine
c'est inadmissible et qu'est ce qu'il
faisait d'autres je ne sais pas ils
doivent être guidés dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée nationale peut être je vois
je vous vois déjà je ne souris pas non
non je vous écoute avec beaucoup
d'attention
vous avez le même regard sur l'autre
député patriotes de quitter en fonction
alors j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
monsieur marie-jeanne bout toutes les
fonctions d' arrêter de dire et du
respect sauvage et très impatients je
n'ai pas terminé
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour monsieur
mario mais il faut savoir que je n'ai
pas terminé
il faut savoir que monsieur marie-jeanne
mon grand père paternel a été un adjoint
monsieur marianne est moche image n 6
bat hugo la martinique
je suis contre le cartonnage qu'il a mis
en place à l'égard de monsieur je fais
le boulot donc je suis totalement contre
donc jean philippe miller a du mal à va
pas si bien dormir que ce à partir des
prochains jours parce que vous serez sur
le terrain à il veut attendre à me voir
partout
il faut qu'ils apprennent à me voit
partout notamment de ce que nous
appelons le député de challenge que nous
sommes en train de mettre en place
il s'agira pour nous de nous mettre dans
la peau de tout de tout c'est de toutes
ces zones et de toutes ces femmes dans
la vie de tous les jours afin de porter
à l'assemblée nationale
on va dire leur souffrance sur nos
vestes
il n'y aura pas toujours faits qui leur
est également si versailles soutane ah
oui je respecte madame side soutane et
son levier en soutane je lui disais que
quand on se présente aux élections
législatives on ne dit pas je suis très
content d'être d'être en lice ou le
débuté mais pour la députation
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin de
paris rappelle que vous êtes je termine
en disant fifi raviné phi phi phi phi se
reconnaîtra et j'ai monsieur jean phi
phi merci cet hybride marie candidat du
simple démocratique de martinique
candidats pour les législatives du mois
de jeu prochain dans le sud merci bonne
journée
[Musique]
des cris